[Música]
llegó el espacio para hablar de medio
ambiente en france24 nos saluda bar y
aclara calle hoy hablaremos de la crisis
hídrica que vive chile y es que la
situación está en tal punto que la
región metropolitana de santiago donde
está la capital presentó un protocolo de
cuatro fases para racionar el agua si es
necesario la alerta verde prioriza el
uso de aguas subterráneas la temprana
restringe la presión del agua y la
amarilla la reduce y prepara los
recursos de emergencia en la alerta más
grave la roja se usaría en esos recursos
de emergencia y habría cortes de agua
que podrían durar hasta 24 horas y
repetirse entre cada 4 o cada 12 días
dependiendo del sector
con ese plan la región capital chilena
se prepara para evitar que el agua
desaparezca por completo o el día 0 como
se le conoce un escenario al que ya se
han enfrentado grandes urbes las
autoridades de ciudad del cabo en
sudáfrica calcularon que para abril de
2018 se quedarían sin una sola gota de
agua y por eso limitaron el consumo a 50
litros diarios por persona cuando antes
se usaban hasta 350 litros en un día
finalmente los planes funcionaron y
evitaron llegar al día 0 aunque santiago
todavía está lejos de un panorama
similar los ríos que lo abastecen están
cada vez más secos el maipo provee el
70% del agua que consumen en la región
metropolitana y ahora tiene sólo un
tercio de su caudal histórico y el río
mapocho otra fuente principal tiene una
décima parte
sobre el tema hablamos con alex godoy
director del centro de investigaciones
en sustentabilidad de la universidad del
desarrollo en chile y revisor experto
del reporte del ipcc le preguntamos si
santiago podría enfrentarse a un día
cero y esto fue lo que respondió
podría existir lo diría
hay dos sus cuencas las ubica el mapocho
es la más vulnerable porque no tiene
obras de mitigación y adaptación al
cambio climático mientras que en la sub
cuenca del maipo si existen obras de
mitigación no obstante ambas dependen de
la pluviometría nosotros estamos
viviendo un fenómeno de la niña que hace
significa que significa que se reduzcan
las precipitaciones y obviamente
significa que se reduzcan los causes
pluviales pero también se los propios
superficiales pero también un fondo se
reduzcan los reservas desde agua la más
vulnerable la sub cuenca del mapocho que
afecta a 3 comunas digamos de santiago y
si no no tenemos hoy día lluvias lo que
vamos a tener en el en el sector sur de
santiago un tipo racionamiento puede
llegar el día cero sí y vamos a ver cómo
podemos salir eso la gran capital en
todo chile ha habido una sequía por 13
años continuos y eso se padece en el
agua el gobierno estima que la
disponibilidad del recurso hídrico ha
disminuido entre un 10 y un 37 por
ciento en los últimos 30 años y para el
2060 en las zonas norte y centro del
país el agua se reducirá en un 50%
hoy nos explica que esto es en parte por
la crisis climática y también por no
gestionar adecuadamente la demanda en un
fondo se junta un fenómeno natural que
tiene que ver exclusivamente del impacto
el cambio climático como se debe también
a una no gestión de la demanda en
términos de incentivar la reducción en
el consumo por ejemplo en chile nunca se
ha tenido una política industrial en
términos de permitir o no ciertos
cultivos que son intensivos en usos
hídricos lugares donde obviamente la
cantidad de agua no es la habitual para
ese tipo cultivo será existió más bien
una especie de dejar libre un poco de
calor y cultores que utilicen distintos
tipos de campos de acuerdo al precio de
los cultivos las consecuencias de la
crisis hídrica que atraviesa chile son
más que evidentes en lugares como el
lago peñuelas en la región de valparaíso
este embalse está seco casi por completo
uno de los guardabosques del lugar habló
con nuestra corresponsal patricia luna
esta es su historia
pero nos encontramos en la parte que es
la parte más profunda del embalse
peñuelas y podemos ver acá
lo poco que está quedando de agua en el
embalse
se aprecia también el terreno cómo está
todo resquebrajado producto de la baja
que ha tenido paulatinamente el este
embalse no de las 1.700 hectáreas que
debiese tener en un año o en una
estación normal de embalsamiento lo que
tenemos hoy día acá es supera con suerte
la hectárea de agua o sea estamos
hablando de
un porcentaje bajísimo de la capacidad
normal no llega al 1% este el registro
más bajo que tenemos a la fecha
daños normales con mucha agua podríamos
tener miles de gaviotas asociada al
espejo de agua entre otras muchas
especies lamentablemente lo que vemos
son aves carroñeras que se están
comiendo los últimos peces que están
quedando en el embalse que se están
muriendo ya sea por la falta de oxígeno
o por la temperatura que tiene el agua
lo que se está evidenciando acá es eso
un aumento de la temperatura promedio o
baja pluviometría nos lleva a concluir
de que esto tiene que ver con efectos
del cambio climático
una de las preguntas constantes cuando
se habla de crisis hídrica es que tanto
pueden aportar las personas si consumir
menos agua en el día a día ayuda o no o
si es más que todo responsabilidad de
las grandes industrias
ante esto godoy nos aclaró el panorama y
nos habló de posibles soluciones
primero que la gente entienda que no
significa que porque uno reduzca a uno
hay más disponible al agua para otros
porque no fondo las bocas es un sistema
dinámico que las bocas tomás son
distintas por lo tanto la reducción de
un según de uno de uno no quieran
disponer lea para otro entonces pero el
impacto que tiene un impacto social es
enorme o sea en un fondo que la primera
pregunta que nosotros tendremos que
hacer es uno declarar a chile
directamente como un estado como un
espacio todo el sector central árido eso
es lo primero eso significa cambiar la
forma como continúan las ciudades la
ordenanza las sistemas tarifarios y
segundo que una pregunta que tenemos que
hacer me que bastante seria
cuál es la capacidad de carga o la
capacidad o tener gente del agua en
calma y pon especialmente la capital
quizás santiago ya no es piernas apto
para 8 millones persona en lo mejor
vamos a tener que empezar a hablar de
descentralización pero en términos ahora
de tratar de que la gente empieza a
buscar sectores fuera de santiago porque
quizás hoy día la cuenca del maipo del
mapuche no es capaz de soportar 8 millón
y medio hasta aquí la crónica de medio
ambiente y nos vemos pronto
[Música]